so we're all talking about it right gas
prices on the rise and the spike hit us
here in las vegas seemingly overnight
now we know the price of fuel affects
our entire economy and if you're ride
share or delivery driver your livelihood
really depends on what you're going to
be paying at the pump now sasha loftis
joining us live tonight with more on
this issue sasha
brian and denise this gas station here
in the central valley has gas at 473 a
gallon now that's really startling to
see for all of us
now but those who drive for a living
this kind of change for them is
devastating
a feeling of
just shock and disbelief like oh my like
just oh my gosh robert davison shares
the frustration and uncertainty he's
feeling after seeing a major gas price
hike here in southern nevada i've never
seen him this high ever let alone
driving uber and lyft he's a full-time
ride share driver and says the steep
rise in fuel rates has really hurt his
bottom line you can do the math you're
definitely losing a chunk of your income
regular unleaded gas hit 429 a gallon
friday an all-time record for las vegas
and about 50 cents higher than this time
last month we're starting to see
the effects of what's happening in
russia and ukraine brian gordon of
applied analysis says a lot of this is
due to the war in ukraine
russia supplies around 12 percent of the
world's crude oil as the invasion
continues there's less availability
there is a little bit of a ripple effect
there that we need to be mindful of he
tells me there's no way to tell how long
this will last but says it could get
worse before it gets better i they
buckle up for the time being robert says
he's doing everything he can to save
but he believes this trend may push
others scrambling to make ends meet
completely off the road it's going to
phase out a lot of drivers i think
now gordon says while there is really no
way to tell how long this particular gas
price hike will last he says that those
high inflation rates we've been seeing
those general rates should calm down
towards the end of 2022 reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now